don't gamma and Grampy want to take a
nap that's not insulting to you
Phil I wasn't sleeping I was listening
good for you that is there's a lot of
steps for one day I was talking about
the kids they're treating us like actual
grandparents instead of the the
premature grandparents we clearly are
I'm the only one of my Aqua aerobics
class who doesn't need two noodles
I put the eggs in a cute basket for the
Easter egg hunt I saw it in a magazine
cute Haley oh no honey your dad and I
didn't feel like taking a nap why don't
you give us a job for the party uh well
we could use some help dying those eggs
but why don't you change the party first
oh good idea
Bill wakey wakey okay we got 60 seconds
people we gotta move fast come on come
on come on come on come on come on come
on
come on move faster let's go let's go
let's go let's go let's go
come on out of here now go go go go
thank you so much I love you guys so
much bye
okay I think we actually got away with
it oh no I have to stop saying that that
dude from the party said that his python
was pregnant do you think those could be
her eggs oh my God is one of them
hatching that's so disgusting we have to
cancel the party wait no way we just got
back in with this parent group after our
daughter's biting spree if they didn't
love their kids getting gummed by an
adorable toddler I don't think they're
gonna love their kids getting punctured
by a python ah calm down snakes lay all
their eggs in one dark place I've got
them all here I'm Gonna Run them by the
pet store oh my God it's one of them
moving get them out of here
buddy
and where are you running off to Big
Buddy
this time that man's got more pins in
them than a Tailor's mouth
he never learned how to fall the right
way too proud wait there's a right way
to fall really a follow-up resist the
temptation to break the fall with the
hands land on your bottom aim for the
meat not the bone oh Mimsy
good as new my dear husband such a
gentleman who always opens the bathtub
door for me
second
[Laughter]
we're just remembering something that
happened on our last Negroni crawl in
Frogtown ah Frogtown a bird on a bird
oh you all got the tick tock invite
Bridger from quibby sent out for her
matcha pop-up on Thursday right
you guys down oh yeah that sounds
Frosty
[Music]
small hiccup when I got to the pet store
I was down one python egg which means
there's someone here yeah and I just
checked the living room it's not there
okay nuggets everyone outside it's time
for the egg hunt
[Applause]
makeup
you find it no but I just realized Why
They Call Rolling two ones with dice
snake eggs that's
and what did I realize don't worry I got
this what what's with the bunnies well I
needed a plausible reason to be out in
the yard it's your house okay I like the
costume I found
oh no on it
I have never seen so many pretty ones
that's because I'm the Easter Bandit you
were a little bad last year I know
you get to trade these five eggs for one
solar path light this egg's moving wait
wait
wait wait wait wait wait wait that is a
magic egg oh
close your eyes and make a wish
okay where's my egg disappeared gotta go
oh can I at least get a picture with you
Grandpa
one very quick pick
up
got my own finger sorry
well that's me how'd I do that here we
go
wait I'm getting a call
no in Delaware let it go to voicemail
Jim okay
stop screaming Easter Bunny and one
three got it have a good year everybody
be good especially you
[Music]